un très très de mon ami très bleu Luke
déplacer la grippe bleue je parle ah lucio à
travers le bizutage n'importe quoi de bon d'accord
merci meurt sur la botte tôt je pense
que si jamais vous publiez mon histoire
incroyable cuisinez la coupe ok prêt mais
regardez le vieux  fruit tu paries le verre
skyisblu c'est moi quoi c'est pourquoi
ta caméra se tient là bas f
récupère ce mec merci comment ça
marche là-bas à droite tu as une
webcam ou quelque chose ouais ouais ouais
debout là je l'ai mis là tourne
leur  bombe effrayante regarde celle-ci
ici sur l'air de fiction Oh tout ce qui est bon
après mon ami Jack imposteur bien juste
pour aller lentement s'il
vous plaît je l'obscurité a pris celui-ci semble incroyable
approuver / couper ça veux oh oui
incroyable toi da da ouais regarde ce
côté gauche  de celui-ci ici oh le
mur
Oh
même je vois un peu trop de restauration rapide
je suis sûr d'accord
si
c'est incroyable
je
garçon intelligent mais par la saveur d'abord
je pense que les autres icebergs ont mieux
volé dans un fil que le 12 h  notre gauche
derrière ce 100 rejoignez-moi au fur et à mesure on va
à celui-là on va aller avec les deux
celui-là celui-là dans le magasin maintenant à propos de
moi pour souffler dessus qui était là pour vivre
ou l'autre là-bas ouais ouais
ça  était une copie tupelo chérie tu
veux bien
juste après le texte
le haut de celui-ci reviens ici dans une
minute je chassais vraiment la couleur sur
l'autre d'accord pour que nous puissions l'appeler la
couleur de l'autre rend plus d'accord d'
accord plus  manière percutante Merci Vera
le reste Linkin prend pour t'entendre bien
Crixus salut bébé
c'est Lori
pradoor Peter je peux je pense que j'ai fait
ici le premier tu es là gentiment
le top oui oui un peu pour arrêter je
pense que la voiture  et des stylos sur le dessus d'accord
allez-y encore je veux d'accord d'accord oh je
pense au dessus d'elle ici j'étais la preuve d'
accord de retour à l'autre gros sur le dessus
eh j'ai fini merci regardez reste
ici maintenant belkin basic  731
stop
les autres allaient bien tout le monde trouve
un boulot et je suis détruite
Ella Trudeau yep
tit  ude pour toi ce sera toi Tamia
corolla s humble plus tôt Paladino falafel
parce que gorille les yeux du dos mon
dieu prend un bon coup mais je le
suis gareki pour changer les bandes en une minute d'
accord
ne te nourris pas bien d'
accord arrête de  change-le donc ouais d'accord
là